تغيير محتمل للعبة إذا كان
الخلد nu piravir المصرح به هو أول قرص مضاد للفيروسات يؤخذ عن طريق الفم
لعلاج covid19 ، فهذه
أداة إضافية محتملة
في صندوق أدواتنا لحماية الناس
من أسوأ نتائج كوفيد في
التجارب التجريبية ،
اختبرت شركة ميرك العملاقة الصيدلانية حبوب منع الحمل على خطر
مرضى بالغين غير
مقيمين في المستشفى مصابين بفيروس كوفيد خفيف إلى متوسط 19 من بين 380 مش
ركًا أعطوا حبوب منع الحمل ، تم نقل 28 إلى ال
ستشفى ولم يتوف أي منهم مقارنة بـ 45 ف
المستشفى وثماني وفيات بين أو
ئك الذين تلقوا علاجًا وهميًا ، تق
ل الشركة إن التحليل المؤقت لتلك التجربة أظ
ر أنها قللت من المخاطر  من
الاستشفاء أو الوفاة بسبب كوفيد 19 من
قبل شركة نصف
تخطط شركة Merck للتقدم إلى إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) للحصول على
ترخيص الاستخدام الطارئ في أقرب وقت
ممكن ، ستنظر إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) في
البيانات وبطريقتها المعتادة الفعالة والفعالة ،
سنقوم بفحص البيانات بأسرع
ما يمكن  ربما يمكن لخبراء الصحة التأكيد
على أن حبوب منع الحمل ليست لقاحًا ولن
تكون بديلاً لمنع
العدوى بالعدوى  أفضل
بكثير من معالجتها بعد
أن يكون الأشخاص مرضى. مضادات الفيروسات التي تؤخذ عن طريق الفم
هي بالفعل علاجات أساسية
للعدوى الفيروسية ، ومن
أشهرها عقار تاميفلو الموصوف للمساعدة في
تقصير مدة الإنفلونزا وتقليل
خطر الاستشفاء إذا تم إعطاؤه بسرعة من
أجل الصحة.  أنا ماندي جيثر